Bình biệt bình biệt bế thì bố hồ chiến mình mới đe gí nhận trung hợp được nữ công dịch bằng 8 đổi,
ở hãi mạnh không bệnh nhập viện trong tình trắng ngàn cân trời sợi tóc vì số số khí danh
từ uống thu khả số kêu cường bình trời qua, như không ngờ kỳ sau hai ngày, kỳ cức bùng nương, chán ăn, bụng đau ông ý,
bác sĩ trưởng bán kỳ mắc số số khí danh thế nào khi nhập viện, giữ đến tổ thương suy đa cơ quan trong đó có gàn,
đây là một tông những trường hợp máu đồng về sự khóc lịch và khó lường của số số khí danh.
Không chỉ kỳ số, số số khí danh có thể giữ biến nhận, thầm chỉ kể biến chính quy hiểm trạm thân kinh,
tìm mặt, gàn, nếu không được theo dõi và điểm trị kịch thời, trong số đó, gàn là cửa quang giế bị tổ thương khi mắc số số khí danh,
với số quý đến chính quy phần trăm người bệnh gặp bấm để liên quan đến gàn, từ tăng mẹn gàn trời đến suy gàn cấp,
nếu sẽ ra suy gàn cấp, thể lệ khu quả khỏi các thể lên đến bố miệ vệ phần trăm,
dù đám nhận năm tâm chính năng thiếu của cơ thể nghiêm gàn chỉ có khả năng từ phục hồi khoảng 20 năm,
tưởng thứ 12 năm, truy ra y tế phuyến cáo, số suy gàn có thể kể biến chính có lường và làm phức tạm quá trình điều trị,
vý dù người có bệnh nên sự gàn khi mắc số suy gàn có quy cơ nhập viện cao hơn 1 phẩy bú lường.
Không qua khỏi tăng ba phẩy bú lường, thời gian năm viện cáo dài thêm tham i ba phẩy 1 phần trăm,
và chỉ phí điều trị tổ thẻ tăng hơn 15 năm, cũng theo báo cáo của bệnh viện bệnh dịch đối thành phố Hồ Jí Minh,
chỉ trong bệnh tham đầu năm nay, cứ khoảng 60% xúc dành thì có một cà trở nền,
khoảng 30% xấu này là thể xúc nền và hương 3 phần trăm trời vào thể xúc dành,
suy ra tản hoặc khối hợp cá ba, điều này cảnh đáng báo đồ khi xấu cả xúc dức dành đàn có xu hướng tăng danh vào cao diễn 1 mưa,
mề mắn là nữ công nghiệm 3 bi霸 tối đã hồi phục phuy nhiên,
khu hoại ai cũng mề mắm khi đối mặt với biến chính xúc xúc dịch đặc biệt là ở dân.
Vì vậy, để phòng người xấu xúc phuyết đang người dân cần chủ động thực hiện các biển pháp tiếp thật như,
lại mỏ nơi sinh sản của mối dịch lăng quan báo gầy, hòn chúng mối đốc,
và tiêm chủ, đặc biệt khi bệnh gàn giĩ tính nạn khi hợp tiêm chủ sê suy giám,
vì vậy, việc tiêm chủ cần được thực hiện sống trong quá trình bệnh để cơ thể có được phản ứng biển dịch tối đu,
hãy hành động ngay hôm nay để báo về xúc khỏe mắn thương và gia đình.